j'accueille françoise hardy
françoise hardy mesdames messieurs les
enfants treize enfants
si je m'appelais françoise hardy pour
voir astrologiquement c'est un bon jour
pour faire la voix contrairement à ma
concurrente directe je ne consulte pas
fait un très mauvais jour en faire la
promo de cet album un ep est ce que
d'après les à ce sera un album qui
pourrait marcher sans promo oui ça je ne
sais pas si c'est le genre de question
qu'il faut poser alors l'album de
françoise hardy s'appelle tant de belles
choses et il sera en vue mardi
c'est un album totalement inédit le
dernier album totalement inédite qui ont
passé huit ans s'appelait le danger
c'est vrai et sion avant 8 ans et en
moins mais j'en ai fait entre temps il
avait moitié de chansons et les trois
jeux suivants inédit un oui et vous
l'avez réalisé avec benjamin biolay la
libre et non je n'ai pas dit c'est ce
que mon fils n'arrête pas de me dire tu
as toi si tu lui dis un truc non est ce
que vous racontez
bon alors timide bien non non mais
benjamin biolay
apportez une chanson il ya trois ans
mais sa chanson été réalisés précisément
par monsieur thomas dutronc donc c'est
pas lui qui a réalisé sa chanson pour
une fois d'accord
bon ça c'est fait alain lubrano alain
lubrano wee man et plusieurs chansons
formidable et il m'a dit tu devrais
faire un album comme ça et je me suis
trouvée d'un seul coup avec ces trois
chansons avec deux chansons que thierry
stremler m'avait envoyé et voilà jacques
pied à l'étrier j'avais plus qu'à
jacques nous aussi jacno ça c'est moi
fille mais j'ai encore peur non mais
jacques neau il il avait il avait un
instrumental que je trouvais génial sur
son dernier album et je trouvais je
tentais de celui qui était sur votre
répondeur de téléphone exactement
non ce n'est pas lui c'est juste
françois sont illimitées vient donc
jacno il avait besoin et thomas dutronc
le fameux thomas dutronc
oui et elle a beaucoup travaillé sur cet
album il n'y a pas mal travaillé sur cet
album il m'a amené des musiciens
exceptionnels et lui-même a fait
quelques son guitar que je trouve alors
vraiment fantastique des biens'' thomas
dutronc vous dit il et j'ai la chance
vous dites iv d'où ils doutent ils
aiment les mélodies nostalgiques comme
moi oui comme beaucoup de gens ouais
ses mélodies nostalgiques que vous
écoutez un inlassable le mans et sur
lesquels vous mettez des mots formidable
en général d'ailleurs mais c'est très
très difficile de trouver des mélodies
aujourd'hui il y en a eu tellement qui
ont été faites et c'est presque aussi
difficile de trouver des mots qui n'ont
pas été trop trop dit de tous les désirs
un tout petit peu différente ne serait
ce que par rapport à ce qu'on a fait soi
même déjà auparavant
voilà c'est difficile le père de thomas
dutronc est emballé un bas il est il
était emballé par la chanson tant de
belles choses que je vais faire entendre
voilà c'est ce qui son père